ou
au
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en fait on fait suite à l'appel de la
sorbonne et voilà deux parce que est-ce
que c'est pas des vieux de 60 ans qui
vont choisir pour notre avenir en fait
c'est nous aussi qui décidons de nous
battre pour notre avenir genre de plus
tard
[Musique]
nous on veut pas de ça on veut
certainement pas de sas et on sait très
bien que quand les fachos son pouvoir on
sait jamais quand il les rend quand ils
les rendent il ya une énorme
augmentation de tous ces actes de gens
qui sinon sommes pas forcément laisse
passer mais qui vont se je saurai pas
comment dire qu'ils vont genre se lâcher
quoi et pour qui tout va devenir permis
alors que enfin voilà quoi